i spontaneously met someone on a hiking
trail outside of san francisco she's not
from san francisco
but she had some interesting
observations about what she felt here
during her first trip
to the city this was filmed january 22nd
2021
during the pandemic ignorant
what's what's ignorant western world
they take every single thing for granted
they take waking up in a warm bed every
day they take
having a roof over their head they take
having multiple grocery stores to go to
they take every single thing for granted
so but but your story is you've been
traveling for 15 months
so you haven't been ground down anywhere
during this pandemic okay so what's your
what's your thoughts about san francisco
you've been here how many days
i've been here about a week a little
less than a week i guess five days
um i've never been to san francisco i
really
like the fun parts about san francisco
but there's a lot of fear mongering
um people won't even make eye contact
with you or even
communicate with you you kind of feel
like
it just feels like a lack of humanity
in san francisco um the fear
is at an all-time high i was in la
i don't know three weeks ago
it's very similar to how bad it is in la
and just the
crime and the attitude and the anger and
the rage
it's just pulsating this city it's kind
of hard to see
you can't see it from here it looks
beautiful right yeah that's why when i
came up here i realized how nice it is
to see the city
from this perspective um but being in
the thick of it
it's just kind of heartbreaking
to be completely honest it's it's uh and
i'm sorry because i live
here and uh you have to see it like this
but the pandemic has 10xed
this element of it i think it was always
there to some degree but it's just
gotten 10 times worse
i think that that's exactly kind of what
the symbolism of life is
that the issues that people haven't been
facing have always been there to some
degree but the pandemic has 10xed them
and so san francisco definitely has that
capacity for sure what do you see in the
country though in the u.s since you've
been back traveling around
different states what are your
observations i think you could teach us
something because i haven't really been
many places in the states
recently um i would say
that
the more and everyone being forced to go
inside
the more everyone is consuming the news
uh
the more fearful everyone becomes the
news
is propaganda i mean honestly i learned
this from my friend i went to design
school in new york city in my early 20s
and my friend
was from china and she was like you know
nobody in china watches the news and i
was like
oh yeah and she was like because they
know it's propaganda and i was like oh
really and she was like
yeah they don't consume this because
they know that it's just trying to
manipulate them and she was like why do
people in the united states watch the
news
and i was like i'm not entirely sure but
literally my entire life
everyone wakes up they turn on the news
in the morning and they claim it's
because they want to
find out what the weather is and then
they all just absorb whatever the news
is telling them and then you marinate on
it for the rest of their days
that's what a lot of people are doing in
the country and have been doing because
you've been forced to go within
i do spiritual work myself and
realize that this is mirroring what
people need to actually be doing in
their lives because the way that our
world has been working this entire time
actually isn't working for people every
single person where you're denying parts
of yourself in life where you're
forcing yourself to continue doing
things all of the hate and the anger and
the inner work that you're not allowing
yourself to do
being forced to go within this time was
mirroring where everyone needs to go
within and themselves so that you can
heal
these wounds so you are no longer
controlled by the system
every person's programmed from the
minute that you're born sure your
subconscious is programmed from the age
of zero to seven so if you
don't go back in and realize the
programming that you're holding from all
of your generations and everything
you're not going to heal those wounds
instead of people really doing
a lot of the inner work that they've
needed to do this during this time
everyone's been numbing honestly that's
what i've seen
all over the country everyone's numbing
in some way shape or form everyone's
smoking more weed or drinking more
alcohol or having more sex
they're not actually avoiding or not
avoiding the issues that they actually
need to be doing they are
finding another way to keep pushing away
keep pushing it away
i mean they already came out saying that
more people
if you are recognizing the patterns more
people got divorced during this pandemic
than ever well because it's forced you
to actually realize like hey maybe i'm
not with the right person
more people um left jobs or decided to
create new jobs or started to create
their own thing because they're
realizing i don't want to live my life
this way anymore so i've seen
an influx of multiple things people
completely walking away from life that
they've had before realizing like i
don't want to actually live my life this
way anymore
and also um creating new things or
moving in a new direction in their life
what i've done i mean
i'm not supported in my family you know
moving away
for 15 months and being on my own you
know everyone thinks that i'm just
lost my marbles and off my rocker you're
the most human person i've talked to in
a long time so exactly
i don't really care what they think
because yeah you shouldn't
the problem is nobody's living their
life for them
anymore and we need to start living our
lives for us and so
i hope that with this pandemic i can't
focus on the people who are not
looking in the mirrors that they need to
be looking at i can only focus on the
people who are looking in the mirrors
and being like
i want to be better i want to live
better i want to do better and
i have seen a lot of people actually
doing that and
waking up yes there's been hardship in
this time but we live in a world where
there's
online everything so create something
that you can create an income
from online and if that brings you
happiness or maybe don't bring
income in from it just make happiness
from it
if you're a dancer make youtube videos
about dancing i don't care make
tick-tock videos about dancing
whatever it is that lights a fire in you
do something about it because it lights
a fire in you for a reason
and your name it's kirby buds curvy buds
yeah
cool name thanks so i just met kirby i
was making another video actually and
it was the first person that really
looked at me or smiled at me i know i'm
a scary looking dude but
i didn't have a mask on didn't have a
mask at distance
outside and uh it was just nice to talk
just just talk with someone haven't been
able to do it
in the lovely city of san francisco for
quite some time yeah it's nice
all right kirby thank you thank you
where's the next journey where's the
next place
um i'm going down to joshua tree then
sedona
then austin then back to mexico because
actually when i was in mexico for
three months at the end of december i
didn't feel like there was a pandemic at
all and i'm trying to live my life like
that
they're a little more chill yeah you
just everyone's just happy
wow thank you
thank you